For the ladies present today,
congratulations on an amazing accomplishment.
You should be proud of all that you have achieved
to this point in your young lives.
I want to speak directly to you briefly because I think it is you,
the women, who have had the most diabolical lies told to you.
How many of you are sitting here now,
about to cross the stage
and are thinking about all the promotions and titles
you are going to get in your career?
Some of you may go on to lead successful careers in the world,
but I would venture to guess that the majority of you are most excited
about your marriage
and the children you will bring into this world.
I can tell you that my beautiful wife, Isabel,
would be the first to say that her life truly started
when she began living her vocation as a wife and as a mother.
I got my bachelor's degree when I was 21,
and I was about eight months pregnant.
And I would have loved to hear this kind of speech on my graduation.
I loved my college experience.
It was incredible.
It was so much fun.
I worked really, really,
really hard those few years,
and I love that I was supported in doing that
and also being coming a mom and being able to say,
you know what?
I have a degree,
I have an education.
It was great, but there's nothing compared to motherhood
and this Is really why I'm here.
Doesn't mean I can't do both.
But it was nice at my graduation
to be supported by my friends and my family
and knowing that my main priority was not going to be
going to a nine to five,
you know, office job.
It was going to be being a mother.
We hear so much praise for women who have careers,
and we're constantly told how important it is
and how wonderful it is for women to get,
you know,
really good degrees and to be CEOs and to be heads of companies,
and that's, like,
the most important thing you can do.
But if somebody dare suggest that something else is more important.
Ever canceled?
You cannot say that.
But to be honest,
some of us really,
really appreciate that kind of encouragement.
And I know all the news organizations,
everybody's freaking out right now. Like,
this is just so horrible.
This man preaching biblical things at a Catholic school.
Like, how dare he?
Doesn't he know that he needs to fall in line
with what society has deemed
appropriate for women to celebrate?
Actually thought it was really sweet, and I liked it.